a rare opportunity to speak to myanmar's
military leaders
and the man who's become the public face
of the Junta Major General zorman Dunn
they say they have good news a pilot
project to allow the rohingya minority
who fled in 2017. come home first we
will accept them back after that we will
process them through camps for a maximum
of two weeks then we will relocate them
to their original villages we have
already prepared security for them
a group of officials crossed from
Myanmar to Bangladesh last week to
discuss the plan with the rohingya
community previous attempts at
repatriation have failed in part because
the Myanmar authorities would not allow
them to return to their original homes
now they seem at least to be showing
more concern
government officials from Myanmar are
present to facilitate our repatriation
and it will inquire about our welfare
and how we came here
the situation in the camps in Bangladesh
goes from bad to worse this fire at the
beginning of March left 12 000 people
without shelter and the UN says the
International Community is failing to
provide funding for even basic Food
Supplies
but for many rohingya safety is their
main concern
yes we guarantee their security we have
already made the preparations to make
them safe for the first batch we are
going to accept between 1 000 to a
maximum of 1500.
throughout the interview however the
spokesman referred to the rohingya as
Bengal is
denying their long history as citizens
of Myanmar and many people will be
skeptical of security guarantees from
the military
in 2017 tens of thousands of rohingya
were killed and hundreds of villages
burned to the ground in a military
Crackdown the UN described as a textbook
example of ethnic cleansing
there is one very big difference between
now and 2017 when more than a million
rohingya fled the country the army that
was accused of perpetrating atrocities
against them has now seized control and
the crimes that we saw perpetrated
against the rohingya are being seen all
across the country Tony Chang Al Jazeera
Myanmar